hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Monster Hunter again
today is Thursday technically it should
be out tomorrow but in terms of time
zones it is out the spring blossom event
has just arrived and I haven't and I
have tons of videos coming out with how
to get some of the new stuff as well as
some decent and vent quests that you're
going to be needing to be keeping track
of this one in particular is for you
great sword users and this is going to
be how to get the wyvern ignition great
sword and basically in the event tab it
is called the every hunters dream it is
a star rank 5 and requires hr8 to unlock
now I'm going to butcher this name I
apologize but you're going to be needing
to fight a rathalos and Apollo omou I'm
pretty sure I [ __ ] that name up so
hard but basically if you need to get
the fight over with quickly rathalos is
weak to dragon in thunder while Paolo is
going to be a weak to fire and thunder
so definitely use those weapons if you
have any of those lying around once you
beat him you're going to be getting the
master blueprint and you're going to be
needing two of those to craft the first
portion of it but regardless once that's
over just get and get your master
blueprint get your extra HR all that
good stuff go to the smithy and craft
your ignition great sword and like I
said it's going to require to master
blueprints 7 dragon eye ores to rathalos
myrrh and to Paolo webbings
the base weapon damage is going to be
720 I believe for the first one and for
the upgraded one it's going to be 1008
with two level 1 decorations 2
augmentation slots and then hidden a
fire element with about 500 damage if
you have one of those armor pieces or
any of those that unlock the hidden fire
element this is probably putting to what
the community has said one of the
greatest great swords that is going to
be in the game so definitely grab that
while you can and also it looks amazing
and it's a community-made one so
definitely showing love to the creator
on that one anyways to end the video I'm
just gonna show off the rest of the
gameplay of me kicking these two
monsters asses with dual blades with
some nice lo-fi hip-hop music and some
chill vibes in the background if you
guys do want to watch that if not that's
completely fine you can click off the
video now either way guys like the video
if you guys did enjoy would has helped
me out subscribe if you're new I got a
lot of Monster Hunter videos with solo
guides and I'm doing tons of these
videos on the spring blossom event
whenever they come out with new stuff
and all that good stuff regarding this
event since that has just released my
two most recent Monster Hunter videos
are going to be on screen at the end of
this video if you guys do want to check
that out and with that guys hope every
great yesterday and
[Music]
[Music]